agitators not educators
that's the focus of tonight's angle
what is today falls church virginia was
an
early colonial settlement dating back to
the late 1600s
now it was founded in 1734 and derived
its name from
the falls church an episcopal
congregation
now it didn't become its own independent
city until 1948
when parents there successfully obtained
its separation
from fairfax county in an effort to
establish
a highly acclaimed school system huh
well 72 years later falls church has
abandoned
its original mission just as hundreds of
school systems across america are using
the covet excuse
the falls church school board since last
march
has closed its schools for in-person
learning and it's turned its student
body
into zoom bots locked onto screens for
hours a day
of virtual learning where kids are
learning virtually nothing
now despite no evidence that schools are
major spreaders of the coronavirus
despite the fact that even dr fauci and
the cdc have said that schools should be
open
the leftist educrats in falls church
have refused to bring
students back full time just like in the
nearby liberal enclaves of fairfax
county and montgomery county maryland
but don't think that during the
shutdowns
falls church school board hasn't been
keeping itself
very busy with other important work on
tuesday night
it unanimously voted to rename two of
its schools
thomas jefferson elementary and george
mason high
now these founding fathers apparently
offended radical activists
and the school board chair total
pushover
greg anderson just rolled over
so after deep and careful consideration
of everything i've heard
and read i conclude that renaming both
schools is in the best interests of our
students
and a necessary part of our equity work
equity work and yet they ignore
the fact that poor and immigrant kids
are losing more ground
every day that they keep these schools
shuttered equity
please these people don't believe in
equity they believe in
power they're not educators they're
agitators
if our mandatory public schools make
some of our own students feel less
worthy
because of the name over the door that
is a big problem
no child should ever have to be in a
building where they feel
marginalized i believe we need to find
names that are welcoming to all
welcoming to all like countless other
schools nationwide falls church
shelled out thousands of dollars to hire
an educational consultant
to navigate the naming controversy if
you can believe it
funny enough in that recent survey only
26 percent
wanted george mason named a change and
only 23 percent
wanted thomas jefferson's name to change
on the school
so the petty tyrants on the board simply
ignored this
and sided with the purgers of history
parent jennifer santiago saying
well there are many times majority rules
works in the issues of equity
it is the opposite that is needed if the
majority rule worked for traditionally
marginalized groups
we would not have systemic racism
look if these folks really cared
about traditionally marginalized people
students kids
they'd be spending their time working on
opening these schools
after the last vote last night school
board member phil
rettinger brazenly admitted their real
agenda
the critical moment for me was the
presidential election
i was proud that in the falls church
city the democratic candidate whose
views favor equity and inclusion one
with over 81 percent of the vote
however outside a false church
approaching half the country
voted for the other candidate that
candidate put
children in cages he said there were
good people
among the white supremacists marching in
charlottesville
he stoked division at every turn i am
appalled
both by his behavior and what the vote
means for the country
now you don't think these school board
elections are really important
this is where people have to start
running for these seats and not knocking
out these
goofballs just radical rabid leftists
now i bet after seeing this millions of
americans are appalled
because they don't really know they're
not really thinking about
how politicized education has become
it's clear that children uh and their
learning their well-being
aren't concerns for these neo-marxists
that are running the education
it's all about remaking america we need
to fight
inequality and racism with action we
need as we are
to reform curriculum and work to educate
students to understand the meaning of
history
a diversity equity and inclusion policy
for our schools that unites us
and specifies further action we should
instead make a statement that we believe
all people are created equal thomas
jefferson wrote
almost those very words and we can
better live
up to the goal he set by no longer
having a school
named for him i mean
that that man could be within a hundred
yards of any school
should terrify all of us this aggressive
campaign of
wokeness and rewriting history is
happening all across america
in fargo north dakota where students are
in a hybrid learning model
the school board is spending its time
virtue signaling about its horrible past
if dakota is the chosen name i think we
would want to do work to make sure that
we're not offending a community
by assigning a mascot that's associated
with the name as well
what are we really hoping is going to
happen as a result of
a new name for the current school named
woodrow wilson
and um you know is it to honor someone
is it to build a story i'd like to make
a motion that the board select dakota
high school as the new name for woodrow
wilson high school
well that motion of course passed
yesterday the day before that a school
district in saint paul minnesota decided
that having a school named after the
state's first
governor was also far too triggering
i think this ripple effect of creating a
culture
of division where some people feel less
than where some people feel singled out
where some people feel like
they're not um real people
waiting on this issue prolonging this
issue keeping this
name lingering around knowing what we
know
is sort of a public endorsement
a public endorsement
and you can bet that the teachers unions
think all of this nonsense is fantastic
everyone's a victim in this game these
liberal school boards don't blink
without consulting the nea and aft
first and that brings us to joe biden
you don't just have a partner in the
white house you'll have an na member in
the white house
and if i'm not listening i'm going to be
sleeping alone in the lincoln bedroom
what will you do to get kids back in
school it takes a lot of money to get
them back the estimates are
150 to 200 billion dollars for the year
would take to get
safely open our schools now republicans
shouldn't give them a penny we know that
they're just going to use that cash to
hire more consultants
and more propagandists who teach our
kids
to hate america its founders and its
founding documents
kids are going to learn how rotten our
country is how racist our founders were
and how ignorant most americans are
now these education bureaucrats should
focus on the real problem
school closures are harming our children
this from the aap
american school district from coast to
coast have reported the number of
students failing classes
has risen by as many as two or three
times students learning from home skip
assignments or school altogether
so here's a pop quiz for the educrats
what's more damaging to a child
the name on the school building or being
kept
out of it for months and that's the
angle